I know that 2 plus 5 makes 7 and 4 plus 10 makes 14, so I really have 7/14. We
need to remember that when working with fractions, we can only simplify factors.
We can only take out numbers that appear both in the numerator and in the
denominator. So I can take out a 7. I know that 7 is the same as 7 times 1 and
14 is the same thing as 7 times 2. So the 7's reduce to give me 1. And I'm left
with 1/2. If you chose 1/2, nice work. We want to be careful when carrying out
this math. There are some other options that you might have thought about. You
might have thought about dividing 2 and 4 by 2, and 5 and 10 by 5. If you would
have cancelled out the terms, you would have gotten 1 plus 1 over 2 plus 2. This
simplified to 2 force, which is the same as 1/2. But this thinking isn't
correct. We know that we can only simplify factors. That is, numbers that appear
in the numerator and the denominator as multiplication. We can't simplify terms.
We did get the correct answer using this route. But it's not the correct mode of
thinking when we simplify fractions. Some students work from here and then split
up this fraction into 1/2 plus 1/2. We know this isn't correct thinking because
we have a division bar. We have to keep our numerator together and our
denominator together. Besides, we were canceling terms and not factors.